bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
vidéo d'après film dédié à spider man
aux ehome ça y est nous y sommes il est
enfin sorti nous l'avons enfin vu quoi
c'est ça y est c'est terminé les mêmes
les fameux lic est tous là on a enfin le
produit fini et
que dire à part qu'elle filme quoi avant
d'aller plus loin évidemment je préfère
vous prévenir que la vidéo va spoil
sévèrement le film de spider man aux
romains évidemment si nous voulons
traiter de certaines choses de certains
mystères et m quelques petites théorie
par exemple des trucs comme ça ben va
falloir que je soulève certains éléments
du film donc voilà vous êtes prévenus
bon maintenant que nous sommes entre
personnes
qui connaissons la vérité
quel master class en vrai sincèrement
nuevo me fait partie pour moi là des
meilleurs films marvel ils égalisent
complètement avec infinity ward et
endgame et en vrai quand j'ai vu le film
je le ressentais vraiment comme un âne
game dédié à spider man et son univers
avec tous les vilains et puis les trois
spider man quoi c'est vraiment spider
man méritait clairement d'avoir un film
comme ça un jour ou l'autre le même est
devenu réalité une petite rumeur datant
de fin 2019 se retrouvent dans nos et
home en fin 2021 c'est fou quel bonheur
de revoir toby et andrew franchement et
puis en plus ça dépasse même le fan
service puisqu'ils ont vraiment leur
utilité ils ont vraiment une présence
quoi bon bref essayons de rester un
minimum structurés je souhaitais
commencer la vidéo en vous parlant du
phénomène de manipulation des traileurs
effectivement on s'est fait avoir sur
beaucoup d'éléments concernant le film
et pour cause les trailer ils sont pour
quelque chose dans cette ère du leak où
la moindre information avec décortiquer
et traqué par la toile la toile internet
spider man vous l'avez et bien les
trailer sont aujourd'hui conçu avec des
fausses informations pour conserver le
maximum de surprises le plus frappant a
été le cas de strange dans les thrillers
strange nous a été montrée comme
malicieux agissant complètement dans le
dos de wang au point même que beaucoup
étaient partis dans le délire de
méphisto ou de dark dr strange et donc
qu'il n'était pas un véritable docteur
strange alors qu'en fait il est juste
chill il débat avec wang concernant le
sortilège et au final ce dernier
l'autorisent nous sommes à des années
lumière de ce que nous montrer les
trailer nous avons eu le cas aussi avec
l'effacement des trois speedy même si
c'était hyper grillé et puis le trailer
brésilien avait fait l'erreur de fuite
et le coup de pied que se prendre les
arts bref voilà tout ça pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans les thrillers il y a
carrément des scènes tournées exprès
pour ces derniers et pareil pour les
effets spéciaux on est quand même loin
de l'époque d'infinity ward ou la simple
manipulation trailer que nous avions
c'était la présence de banner en hulk
pour ne pas faire fuiter le fait que
banner n'arrivait pas à se transformer
bref méfions nous des thrillers et
gardons un peu de recul par rapport à
ses derniers bons et concernant le film
maintenant au final beaucoup de licques
était vrai je pense notamment à la
présence de daredevil dans le film qui
au final a été confirmée par kevin fait
guy lui même le président de marvel
studios quelques jours avant la sortie
du film la présence de matt murdock dans
no et home même si elle ne dure que
quelques secondes et très importante
c'était très intelligent de le placer là
car même si nos et omet incroyable 1 et
bien marvel studios et sony ne sont pas
dupes ils savent à quel point le film
est attendu et à quel point les gens
vont aller en masse le voir donc placé
dardé ville juste quelques secondes dans
le film eh bien ça permet de l'utiliser
pour la suite du mc ou devant un maximum
de personnes et donc forcément attiré
beaucoup plus de monde à regarder les
films et les séries matt est clairement
un easter egg et c est son utilité mais
cela a été fait de façon cohérente et il
y aura un impact pour la près d'ars des
villes est un héros majeur de marvel qui
n'a pas encore été véritablement
introduit car je rappelle que les séries
netflix de marvel ne sont plus canon
depuis l'arrivée des séries disney plus
ce dernier est lié à énormément de super
héros de la firme il est attendu
notamment pour apparaître dans la série
scholl qu il est beaucoup liée à eco
également et par conséquent le caïd
certains vont comprendre de quoi je
parle mais bon no spoil 40 raids
seulement de nos et comme dans cette
vidéo bref ce petit teasing dans cet
énorme blockbuster est très bien pensé
maintenant il faut que nous parlions du
cas des vilains et de l'impact des trois
pays concernant les sinister bon déjà
les sinister commandes pensais c'était
symbolique qu'autre chose effectivement
c'est juste cinq mecs allez on va dire 6
avec la présence de venom et qui sont
perdus du coup dans un autre univers et
qui n'avait pas envie de mourir tout a
été super bien respecté les personnages
sont clairement les mêmes qu'à l'époque
octavius et le goût de gueye qui se fait
juste manipulé par cbre à flint marco
n'a rien contre ce pays 10 étaient en
bon terme avec le peter de toby et
cetera et cetera petite mention quand
même à willem dafoe qui était vraiment
ultra chaud et ultra creepy quand même
mais là où c'était vraiment super c'est
le fait que les trois spider man et
soigner leurs vilains iconique cela a
permis en fait de clore définitivement
les histoires de toby et andrew est
justement de réparer leurs erreurs de
l'époque par exemple l'affrontement de
toby et du bouffon vert a été mal gérée
à l'époque puisque dans sa crise le
bouffon c'est tu es tout seul et c'est
quelque chose qui a changé
définitivement l'histoire du spider man
de toby puisque par conséquent son
meilleur ami harry fils de norman osborn
voulait se venger et a tenté de tuer
peter à de nombreuses reprises ce qui en
a découlé s'est énormément de souffrance
la perte d'un meilleur ami et même au
final la mort de ce dernier et justement
c'est quelque chose qui a été soulignée
dans le film toby malgré son âge avancé
et la mort de norman il ya maintenant
des dizaines d'années était toujours
rongée par cet accident et cherchait
encore aujourd'hui un sérum pour le
soigner et on retrouve le cas également
pour électro qui meurent faso peter
dennebroeucq octopus qui se sacrifient
alors que s'il avait été raisonné avant
on n'en serait pas arrivé là on le
rappelle mais spider man n'est pas un
héros qui tue ce dernier cherche
toujours la meilleure solution
et cette thématique d'aider les gens est
toujours complexifier par les vilains
iconique de l'araignée puisque ce ne
sont pas de véritables
antagonistes énervé dédié au mal comme
un thanos par exemple qui est convaincu
et qui pour lui c'est la victoire ou la
mort mais du coup le fait d'avoir soigné
les vilains de chaque film possède un
impact particulier puisque au final leur
destin va changer un simple grain de
sable peut tout dérégler si norman a été
soigné avant sa mort cela signifie qu'il
ne va pas s'auto tué par accident dans
un excès de folie et par conséquent cela
veut dire que toby n'aura pas de
problème avec harry son meilleur pote et
donc pas d'affrontement et de souffrance
vous voyez ce que je veux dire cependant
quelque chose de vous trotter en tête
est ce que nos héros mme annule donc les
anciens films spider man et bien
personnellement je dirais que non
puisque de par la présence des anciens
vie l'un des anciens films spider man
dans no et home est également la
présence des deux spider man iconique
cela signifie donc que ces derniers sont
canons à l'univers du mca et par
conséquent qu'ils sont touchés eux aussi
par les événements de la série de l'opi
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
modifier le destin des vilains a créé
pour chacun d'entre eux un événement
nexus pour rappel un ex us c'est quand
quelqu'un s'écarte du chemin qu'il doit
parcourir et qui finit donc par créer
une autre branche pour faire simple on
va prendre l'exemple de l'eau qui
normalement à la fin du premier round
gers lot qui se fait battre et capturé
par nos héros puis thor va leur amener
sera ce garde pour qu'il soit jugé
sauf qu'avec le voyage dans le temps
d'avengers endgame tony par erreur fait
tomber le tesseract au pied de l'eau qui
ce qui va lui permettre de s'échapper et
donc par conséquent de ne pas être
ramené sur as garde ne pas se faire
juger etc etc une petite erreur qui
change complètement le cours de
l'histoire est bien ici c'est pareil si
nous prenons un autre vilain par exemple
électro et bien le fait qu électro soit
soigné et raisonnée va créer un nexus
soit une autre ligne ou l'antagoniste
n'est donc pas mort ce qui va changer
complètement l'histoire puisque du coup
peut-être que par rapport à sa survie ce
dernier pourrait possiblement empêcher
la mort de wayne stacy car le combat se
terminerait bien avant l'arrivée d'harry
osborn par exemple et du coup andrew
n'aurait pas la même évolution puisqu'il
n'aurait pas souffert concernant la mort
de cette dernière ou sinon par exemple
pour le lézard le fait qu'il soit soigné
et raisonnée engendrerait un nexus ou
possiblement le capitaine stacy ne
mourrai pas ce qui changerait l'histoire
du spider man andrew et cetera et cetera
etc j'espère avoir été assez clair dans
mes propos mais du coup la création
d'événements nexus est intéressante
puisque cela permet de ne pas dénaturer
les anciens films de spider man il
serait toujours aussi légitime et noé
home viendrait juste épicé ces derniers
en créant une seconde ligne temporelle
on va dire quoi ensuite il faut que nous
parlions du sortilège de dr strange et
par extension de la fin du film et de
l'avenir de spider man le sortilège est
plutôt particulier et m'intrigue sur
certains points à la fin du film ce
dernier a fait oublier à tout le monde
que peter était spider man au final
peter de par les événements du film fera
le choix de ne pas renouer le contact
avec ses proches certainement pour les
protéger une thématique importante du
héros est une sacrée leçon certainement
transmis à fortes chances par andrew et
toby de par leur vécu cependant cela ne
peut pas être aussi simple le film a
bien pris le temps de nous montrer le
résultat du sortilège notamment par
rapport à mj ou encore happy avec la
scène du cimetière et je pense
sincèrement que ces scènes cachent
certains éléments déjà en termes de
récits d'évolution des relations et des
histoires des personnages c'est risqué
de faire disparaître des intrigues
importante juste avec un sort de pertes
de mémoire pour moi jamais de la vie
marvel et sony supprimerait tout ce qui
a été établi avec mj par exemple et
remettre trois films pour reconstruire
tout ça soit il décide de m mj de côté
pour nous dire que ça y est c'est fini
elle a oublié peter leur histoire
s'arrête là et basta ce qui est
impossible pour moi car mj est trop
importante dans l'histoire de spider man
surtout que toby nous a prouvé que
malgré sa condition d'araignée et son
grand âge il est toujours avec sa mgi et
sans oublier également que zendaya est
une actrice vedette donc je ne pense pas
qu'il se passerait d'elle soit du coup
et c'est ce que je pense c'est que son
histoire avec peter n'est pas totalement
terminée et que tout n'a pas été balayés
en fait les gens ont oublié que peter
était spider man mais n'ont pas oublié
leur histoire avec spider man à voir
comment a fonctionné le sort mais cela
voudrait dire que mj ici elle réfléchit
à son vécu avec spider man elle aurait
comme une sorte
de bugs comme s'il y avait un élément
manquant à tout ça par exemple si on
prend le cas de happy ce dernier
affirmait à peter qu'il connaissait mais
grâce à spider man mais s'il prend le
temps de réfléchir à la question s'il
réussi à refaire le lien entre mai et
spider man il pourrait retrouver
l'identité de peter enfin bref tout ça
pour dire qu'il ya un truc bizarre avec
le sortilège possiblement strange a
réécrit la réalité et modifier le vécu
pour que tout le monde oublie peter sans
avoir à se poser de questions mais en
soi cela reste un sortilège une perte de
mémoire n'est pas définitive du coup par
rapport à la fin du film le sortilège va
permettre à peter d'effectuer sa
véritable évolution en tant que super
héros il n'est plus lié à personne il a
perdu son appui principal tente mais il
va devenir adulte et responsable
je trouve d'ailleurs qu'il ya une
certaine vibe à la tobey maguire à la
fin du film avec une petite chambre pas
ouf avec un loyer à payer je ne serais
même pas surpris que tom deviendrait
livreur de pizzas pour payer ses
factures et on retrouve également les
moments où ils écoutent les fréquences
de police pour intervenir plus
facilement on le retrouve d'ailleurs
avec le costume iconique de spider man
des comics créée par ses soins du coup
vu qu'il est tout seul bref peter
commence à épouser clairement son rôle
d'araignée et c'est le début d'une
nouvelle ère qui commence petit mot
concernant l'aide il ya une scène où
justement toby et andrew expliqué anne
aides que leurs meilleurs amis étaient
devenus des super vilains et du coup ce
dernier expliquait qu'il ne deviendrait
jamais un ennemi de peter et de spider
man alors il est vrai qu'à la base et ce
même dans les comics ned est un
véritable allié de spider man mais il y
à un élément intéressant c'est que ned a
été ré êtes avec le sort de pertes de
mémoire il a oublié toute son histoire
avec peter ils ne sont plus du tout à me
donc il y as possibilité pour moi un
jour que ned puisse être un ennemi de
spider man surtout que beaucoup
théoriser sur le fait qu'il puisse
devenir le ôb gobeline un vilain qui
n'est jamais encore apparu à l'écran
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui pour moi c'est
une possibilité concernant venom les lic
étaient donc vraies et au final comme on
le disait dans la précédente vidéo ce
n'est pas plus mal le venom incarné par
tom hardy et particuliers et n'aurait
pas coller spécialement avec les autres
vilain du film qui étaient tous liés de
parler précédent film justement et les
anciens spider man mais surtout il y à
une dinguerie concernant venom quand
strange a expliqué les conséquences du
sortilège à peter il lui affirme que le
sort a eu pour effet de faire apparaître
des gens qui connaissent l'identité de
spider man des gens qui connaissent donc
l'identité de peter parker
bas du cou qu'est ce qu'il fout là venom
sony nous cache énormément de choses et
si dans le film marvel a bien profité
nous introduire des gros éléments comme
daredevil ou carrément la bande annonce
de doctor strange 2 et bien sony en
profite également le président de sony
lui même l'avait affirmé il y a un plan
pour lier le sony verse et le mc eu et
ce plan est en cours de production ce
n'est pas un hasard si une nouvelle
trilogie lié à spider man a été
confirmée mais du coup comment expliquer
la présence de venom j'ai peut-être une
piste mais en vrai il existe énormément
de possibilités et nous sommes encore
très loin d'avoir les réponses de ce que
nous savons sony développe son univers
avec les villains de spider man c'est
pourquoi on a déjà eu deux films venom
et beaucoup d'autres qui sont prévus
pour l'avenir comme craven par exemple
qui à la base devait être le méchant
dédié pour nos héros mme et bien parmi
ces films nous avons morbius qui arrive
très prochainement et nous savons que ce
dernier se passe dans le même univers
que venom sauf que dans le trailer de
morbius il y a des références à spider
man une en particulier un poster avec
écrit marc d'horreur soit sur ou
assassin personnellement je ne pense pas
que ce soit une simple référence pour le
fun ou à une coquille une erreur quoi
les enjeux sont trop grands surtout
depuis que sony souhaite pleinement se
lier au mca mais surtout il y un détail
très important qui expliquerait une des
raisons de pourquoi venom est arrivé
dans le mca c'est le symbiote dans la
scène post générique de venom de venom
devient bizarrement attiré par peter
quand ils le voient à la télé on peut
penser que c'est parce que venom est
intimement liée à peter dans son
histoire comme dans les comics mais il
se pourrait que ce soit plus profond en
fait dans nos et home et d'y jouer par
tôt mardi semble complètement perdu il
ne comprend pas du tout où est ce qu'il
est et la seule piste qu'il a du coup
pour trouver des réponses avant de
repartir dans son monde c'est d'aller
voir le garçon de la télé il parle de
peter évidemment mais il réagit comme
s'il ne voyait pas du tout qui c'était
pour moi si eddie brock voulait voir
peter c'est parce que venom réagissent
et bizarrement face à sa présence à la
télé et c'est possiblement une
thématique que nous explorions dans
spider man 4 est possiblement venom 3 et
cela expliquerait pourquoi le quatrième
film du coup de spider man serait dédiée
à venom il semble y avoir un lien caché
entre les deux personnages qui va réunir
le sony verse et le mc hull et dont on
n'est pas encore au courant enfin on va
terminer avec un petit mot sur strange
quand même la vidéo commence à être bien
longue encore une fois on précipite le
docteur j'étais surpris qu'il ne soit
pas désigné comme sorciers suprême est
que ce soit ou longue mais au final
c'est tout à fait cohérent et d'ailleurs
si ils l'ont dit dans le film c'est
justement pour éclairer cet élément on
est beaucoup à se tromper quoi et puis
en fait à part le premier film de doctor
strange je ne suis pas bien l'évolution
du docteur dans le mc puisqu'il n'y en a
pas vraiment encore donc le fait que
wang soit le sorcier suprême est logique
puisque effectivement strange été absent
durant les cinq années du snap et
surtout cela explique du couchant çi
dont on avait soulevé la problématique
dans la précédente vidéo néanmoins le
fait que wang soit sorcier suprême n'est
que temporaire nous savons qu'à terme
steven or à ce titre c'est l'ancien elle
même qui disait qu'il serait le meilleur
des sorciers suprême et au vu de la
bande-annonce qui tease une grosse
menace pour k mart âge et le fait que
strange devra sauver la situation il ya
de grandes chances pour qu'il devienne
le sorcier suprême véritablement à la
fin de son second film mais je vous
avoue on ne va peut-être pas trop
s'étaler sur la bande annonce car il ya
beaucoup à dire et ce sera l'objet d'une
vidéo dédiée donc n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour ne rien louper
on va s'arrêter là je pense le film
était très dense il ya énormément
d'informations il ya plein de secrets de
mystère mais en haletant on va pouvoir
analyser et théoriser sur tout ça dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines et les mois à venir nous sommes
dans une nouvelle ère nos réformes signe
la fin d'un chapitre le multivers est
véritablement lancée et nous en sommes
témoins franchement je suis trop content
de cette évolution là je me remets
toujours pas qu'il y ait eu toby et
andrew dans le film et en plus de ça ils
ont rajouté une bande-annonce de doctor
strange de en scène post-générique le
film de doctor strange 2 avec depuis
très longtemps on en a parlé déjà plein
de fois sur la chaîne sans avoir aucune
information et la bad à voir la bande
annonce et c'est que du bonheur aussi
ils ont refait comme à l'époque avec le
premier film captain america où
justement à la fin la scène post
générique c'était la bande annonce pour
le tout premier avengers donc voilà si
on essaye de relier un peu les deux
trucs cela voudrait dire que peut-être
docteur strange 2 serait une dinguerie
ça promet un très gros films quoi enfin
bref vous vous en doutez qui dit grosse
sortie de films marvel dit forcément un
gros trois théories qui arrive et c'est
le cas semaine prochaine 1/3 théorie va
sortir est en très bonne compagnie donc
je compte sur vous pour être là en
attendant n'hésitez pas à laisser un
petit pouce bleus à vous abonner à la
chaîne et puis pas surtout à me laisser
un commentaire sur ce que vous avez
pensé du film vos impressions c'est
vraiment dans ces moments là qu'il faut
profiter d'internet et partager ensemble
sur notre passion commune et puis
n'hésitez pas si vous avez des
interrogations également je pense qu'il
y à de nombreux débats qui ont été
ouvertes sur ce merci à marvel et sony
pour cette master class ce film était
clairement un rêve de gosse je pense
pour beaucoup de gens un énorme plaisir
de nostalgie
toby le goat bref aller que le lay and
round soit avec vous cet art rock allez
ciao tout le monde
[Musique]